my name is andrew quintman i'm assistant
professor of religious studies in the
department of religious studies at yale
university
i work primarily
in
tibetan cultural areas i work on tibetan
buddhism in tibet northern nepal
northern india and bhutan so i've been
working in the himalayas for close to 25
years now i went for the first time in
the late 1980s i was a study abroad
student as an undergraduate
when i went to northwestern india
and nepal
and i've been engaged ever since
one of the things i i'm most fascinated
by about
religious culture in the tibetan tibetan
buddhist world is the great diversity
you find across
geographic regions and throughout time
so we have this kind of uh image of
tibet through history as being sort of
isolated from the world as being a kind
of
uh hidden valley like a kind of
shangri-la set off
kind of timeless set off geographically
from the rest of the world and of course
we know that that has never been the
case that the himalayas although they
are impressive mountains have always
been permeable and there's always been
movement of people and with people of
religious cultures of religious
practices and religious texts and those
movements have happened in many
directions they've happened
from tibet into china back and forth but
they've also moved especially across the
himalayan
boundaries so from tibet down to nepal
and into india and then of course in the
reverse direction as well and what that
means is that we find uh an incredibly
complex conglomeration of religious
cultures of religious activities of
really just beliefs and practices
throughout the
himalayan regions
we find of course
buddhists
who
are practitioners from the kind of i
don't know mainstream tibetan buddhist
tradition
but there are also buddhists
on the nepali side of the border whose
practices are influenced
from slightly different traditions you
find interactions from those buddhists
with the buddhists of the kathmandu
valley of the newars the traditional
inhabitants of the kathmandu valley but
of course
there are also the pre-buddhist
religions known as bun
which stand on their own but also stand
in conversation
with traditional buddhist practices
and then of course we have uh
hindu traditions and
islam and all of these are sort of
working in in some sense in conversation
of course they're also contested on on
occasion
but they really inhabit this
this kind of giant melting pot if you
will that we call the himalayas the way
that that tibetan buddhism is
traditionally understood comes from the
great histories from the great
narratives that tibetan historians that
tibetan authors
have told themselves and have therefore
told us about their tradition and this
is the
view of tibetan buddhism as a great
tradition that has its history
coming largely from india
through the activities of
important figures from the 7th and 8th
century
a great
kind of tantric sorcerer known as
padmasambhava or guru rinpoche in tibet
is known as the second buddha and also
with a series of
great tibetan kings who were great
sponsors of buddhism in tibet
and yet we know that buddhism developed
in very different ways in very different
sort of locations across the tibetan
cultural world and at different moments
in time and those kind of cultural
pockets those pockets of tibetan
buddhist practice were largely informed
by
the kind of communications
that those inhabitants had with people
from other regions with the specific
teachers who were there
my kind of local developments whether
they be kind of literary developments
based upon certain teachers or upon
based upon kind of local cultural
practices one of the projects i'm
currently involved with is together with
a research partner at the university of
virginia curtis shaffer
that we're calling the life of the
buddha in tibet and it's based around
very very interesting and unique
constellation of visual and literary
materials it's based at the monastery
known as jonang punsa ling just west of
shigatse in western tibet
and it's based around
a series of mural paintings depicting
the life of the buddha in exquisite
detail from the 17th century from the
1620s
it's probably the best preserved and one
of the most extensive
murals depicting the life of the buddha
in existence and is remarkably well
preserved
but together with that we have this
amazing collection of literary materials
describing
not only the life of the buddha but also
the kinds of ritual applications in
which the figure of the historical
buddha
was venerated and was sort of
incorporated into the institutional
life of this monastery so what we're
trying to do is look at the relationship
between this really exquisite
representation of the buddha's life
and the buddha's life as depicted in
literature looking at what are the
relationships what are the differences
between literary and visual applications
of the buddha's life but then trying to
look at the role of the historical
buddha
in the creation of a new institutional
identity for this particular monastery
which itself was
was both very active in terms of its
kind of intellectual life it was the
seat
that created sort of new philosophical
ideas in the history of tibetan buddhism
but it was also politically very active
and had the support of the great
political patrons great
patrons of western tibet and were in
some sense at war
with uh the figures of the dalai lamas
and their own patrons in central tibet
and in in lhasa so my new english
translation of the life of milarepa was
recently published with penguin classics
in 2010 and uh this fall i have a new
book coming out with columbia university
press in their south asia across the
discipline series called the yogan and
the madman reading the biographical
corpus of tibet's great saint milarepa
and both of these books
are centered around uh one of the single
most important figures in tibetan
buddhist history and in fact of the
history of buddhism in the wider
himalayan world and this is the 11th
century
yogin and poet named milarepa
he was a figure who was born right on
the himalayan border on the kind of
northern slope of the himalas in a
valley called kirang he was born in the
11th century and spent
most of his time
studying
and meditating and sort of wandering
across this kind of himalayan landscape
both on the tibetan side but also on the
nepali side as well he visited
kathmandu valley and he also meditated
on the nepali side of the himalayas
for for many many years so the figure of
of milarepa and the life story that's
associated with him was really
transformational in the way that
buddhism developed in the himalayan
world
his life story which was written
almost 400 years after he died
is probably the single best known piece
of tibetan literature
in the world
among tibetan buddhists
and it's become one of the
best loved and best known translations
of tibetan buddhist literature in the
west it was one of the first lenses into
tibetan buddhism
that we had in the west through its
translations uh in the early 20th
century so in my new book i try to look
at the life of milorapa as a literary
work
so to try and think about
one of the most important pieces of
tibetan literature
as a true literary work so trying to
understand uh what were its uh it's sort
of
what was its origin point
how did it develop over time and
especially what did its most famous
author in the 15th century the the
acclaimed madman from tsung or western
tibet what kind of
literary tools and tropes and techniques
did he use to create a work of such
lasting genius
to create a work that tibetans
themselves understood was a work of
genius but was understood even by
readers hundreds of years later and from
cultures very distant from tibet could
also understand as a work of literary
genius one of the interesting things
about the most famous version of the
life of milleripa that was created in
the 15th century by this famous madman
of tsung
was that it was the first to be
disseminated uh through the use of print
medium so this was a period in which
block printing was still
fairly uncommon in central to bed
although it had been incorporated
in china for many centuries and had been
used in the kind of margins of the
tibetan cultural world for quite some
time but it was what the the production
of the print version of the life of
milarepa in the 15th century was one of
the landmarks of book creation in the
tibetan buddhist world
now the madman was
was not only a great literature he was
also a genius in marketing and i like to
think of him as one of tibet's first
multi-media
marketing men
in that together with his text he also
created
a series of kind of
multimedia forms of the yogin's life so
he commissioned a series of paintings
depicting uh miller ape's life for the
first time and he also uh commissioned
a collection of uh ritual practices
that could be practiced along with the
the texts and sort of in in connection
with the artwork so that we have this
package of texts of image and ritual
practices that the author was then
disseminating to the great to his great
patrons and to the great
centers of learning and practice
throughout the tibetan buddhist world so
we see this connection between
literature between art and ritual
practice
you